come funziona qui No non sono mai venuta
a fare la spesa solito viene la consueta
se ne è andata al suo paese per le feste
e mi ha rovinata Io ho cinque persone a
cena e non so da dove iniziare insalata
di mare Aneto e limone già condita per
caso No allora no no no se la può tenere
da 1le foglie di patate al Team tante
patate dentro No no allora non la posso
mi si ripropongono sicuramente per
curiosità una cassetta di gamberi Rossi
che ho letto lì no quanto quanto vengono
sta scherzando Ho capito che vengono da
Mazara del Vallo Ma se prendo l'aereo e
vado a Mazar a prendermeli risparmio Ah
sì Allora se la metto così dirò a tutti
quelli che conosco di non mettere più un
piede qui dentro va bene ladri Allora mi
dai 10 kg di tritato per i polpettoni
un'ottantina più o meno super per giù di
involtini misti bravo dammi anche quelli
Allora 60 calamari ripieni pure insalata
di polpo Abbonda Abbonda mi dai anche
due teglie da 1 Kg ciascuna di gatò di
patate Fammi assaggiare anche il pesce
spada cppa roba ma va quest'anno pochi
siamo perché i parenti della California
non vengono ma saremo 40/50 persone
Infatti mio marito è disperato non è
abituato a fare in pochi capito A
proposito se tu e Giuseppe volete venire
a noi fa solo piacere tanto cibo
sicuramente ce n'è ti ho porto anche tuo
cogn ma ci manco io ormai sono abituata
a fare almeno 100 persone al massimo
compro roba in più